- Darling, you can major
in anything you want,
as long as you become a doctor.
(upbeat music)
(speaking Tagalog)
(speaking Korean)
- All that money I spent
sending you to college courses
when you were in the fourth grade,
and you want to go to video school?
(speaking Korean)
- Your SAT scores are so low.
(speaking Tagalog)
(speaking Korean)
- You don't want to be the first person
from our entire Tamil Sri Lankan community
to go to a community college.
(speaking Korean)
(speaking Tagalog)
- No applying to New York schools.
In New York, everyone does the drugs.
(speaking Tagalog)
- You know, you might
fall into the bad crowd.
(speaking Tagalog)
(speaking Korean)
(upbeat music)
(speaking Tagalog)
- Boys and girls living together?
Shame!
(speaking Korean)